ja ich besuche hier die künstlerin
shirakawa sie wohnt mit ihrer familie
seit 18 jahren inzwischen hochhaus hardy
besser sein
das ist ja wohl fehlen
ich muss sagen aber ich ziehe dann
schaut liao h aber die haben auch auf
das geachtet bei den balkonen und so
dass und er gerne das ist sehr sicher
ist also dass man sich ja sowieso also
man fällt ihr nicht aus wir sind hier
runter aber sobald ich so machen
sie sind der schwede welchem anbieterin
von lava im hoch - wälder grün
ich stamme aus dem iran und aus der
landesklinik großstadt wie man es ja
hierzulande nicht kennt und da ist ganz
normal dass man im hochhaus wohnt eine
ganze familie und auch so ein bisschen
so aufgewachsen und was eigentlich recht
schnellen wunsch zum hier in die
tiermedizin jetzt schon recht lange her
also ich ein referat zur heimat ja und
dann die modernität auch jetzt ist und
wer kenntnis zu modernen wohn und andere
ist sind die vielen nachbarn also
halt auch so aufgewachsen aber kein
partner ist das nicht total also klar
kennt man sich also es ist eben es ist
findet er trotzdem als in der schweiz
statt von dem her gibt es auch ein
gewisses temporeduktion im sinne von
sich kennen werden
es beschränkt sich meistens dann mit
bestimmten leuten auf dem auf die lift
konversation wenn man zb und dann sind
wir halt entsprechend länger oder in der
waschküche und so also es ist schon so
ein freund also es ist freundlich und
man grüßt sich man schwarzmann und so
und dann wo also je nachdem in welchem
ton man wohnt man hat auch anderen
rhythmus und dann gibt es dir die man
halt bewusst treffen weil da muss man
halt mit dem smart machen dann vor ort
ist das wahrscheinlich ganz auge sehe da
sind dann auch nicht so viele freiwillig
als ich noch eingezogen bin waren noch
viele mehr wohnungen subventioniert und
alterswohnungen sozialwohnung
ich habe schon das gefühl dass die
bewohnerschaft sich am ändern ist was
ich nicht nur
das passt schon in mir eine leise wehmut
hervorholte ja das ist es wirklich gehe
aber inzwischen hat der hoch urs boom
auf schweiz erfasst nicht aber die sind
allerdings auch damit einverstanden
höher teurer imposanter die
stadtentwicklung der schweiz zeigt seit
einigen jahren vor allem in eine
richtung nach oben
überall in den größeren städten und
ballungsgebieten schießen die hochhäuser
wie pilze aus dem boden
die schweiz und das hochhaus der beginn
einer neuen großen freundschaft nicht
ganz opposition gibt es etwa beim
geplanten zweiten rostock in basel über
200 meter hoch soll er werden zu hoch
für viele anwohner
sie sehen nur den schatten die grafisch
in zürich sollen zwei hohe wohntürme das
geplante hardturm stadion finanzieren
gegner beschwören das schreckgespenst
eines kleinbahn hatten darauf wir sind
einfach gefühl dass man vertraglich
druckprobe wir jetzt die probe dann hat
das die nächste zwei generationen und
ostsee und wir haben die verantwortung
und stadtbild ist wichtig woher kommt
dieser widerstand gegen das hochhaus der
architekt roland sieger schreibt für das
magazin werk bauen wohnen
für ihn ist das misstrauen tief in der
schweizer mentalität verwurzelt
schweizer sind sehr landet projekts volk
und und a und auch liebe und der zug und
natürlich dass es nie eine royale
tradition gehört wo mix macht der körper
zu unserer nation dazu sondern es ist
einige hof konzern zum föderalismus
sucht und darum wahrscheinlich alles was
die tätigkeit aus was mitmacht dominanz
und die eine erste spur haben die durch
studien im städtebau sind natürlich zu
spät und so hat natürlich hoch es nach
wie vor und schwere stand dabei waren in
den 60er jahren ganz viele hoffnungen
mit dem hochhaus verknüpft es herrschte
wohnungsnot in den städten während der
hochkonjunktur entstanden günstige
mietwohnungen am rande der stadt etwa in
der locher gut überbauung in zürich die
erste euphorie wich aber bald bedenken
für ihre familie interessenten schnell
war die rede von anonymität und von
flammen die medien beförderten die
wachstumskritik
wer hier einzieht lässt seinen traum von
der wohn idylle oder gar von einem
eigenen kleinen häuschen mit garten
fahren und unterzieht sich gänzlich dem
wohn ritus der großstadt im
atomzeitalter
ähnlich die vorurteile später bei den
zürcher hardau hochhäusern zumal dort
viele familien mit geringem einkommen
einzogen
das ganze schwieriges problem sind kennt
wo im haus wohnen wir vermutet hat das
kind im huus aggressiver werde tauss im
normal russ heute wohnen in den neuen
wohn türmen von zürich ganz
selbstverständlich viele familie und das
hochhaus ist ein symbol für die moderne
schweiz und zählt das eigentlich hat es
spiegelt aus fassade von prime tower das
spiegelt ja genau die andere zur
wirtschaftskraft hat nicht nur zur lagen
ist natürlich mit dem bankensektor jetzt
größer natürlich das als zeichen dafür
ist auch in basel stehen die hochhaus
projekte für status und wirtschaftskraft
der region ganze stadtgebiete wie das
dreispitzareal sollen so aufgewertet
werden
[Musik]
hochhaus bauten sind höchst lukrative
investoren projekte meist mit wohnungen
im hohen preissegment
so auch in dübendorf wo der größte
wohnturm der schweiz entsteht
da kann die fantasie schon mal mit den
vermarktern durchgehen
[Musik]